me gustaría que le tuvieras este vídeo e
intentará calcular el área de este
cuadrilátero que está marcado en color
como café para esto una sugerencia es
que lo intentes dividir en figuras más
pequeñas y aproveches la cuadrícula
sobre la cual está dibujado vale bueno
voy a empezar a resolverlo pensando en
que tú ya lo intentaste un rato vamos a
hacerlo de la siguiente manera el chiste
va a ser intentar justo encontrar
figuras más pequeñas y para las cuales
sea fácil calcular su área y que más
fácil sería si los lados son enteros
entonces déjame empezar por ejemplo en
este punto de acá y voy a avanzar hacia
la derecha para ver si me topo con
alguna figura conocida entonces voy a ir
avanzando avanzando avanzando y al
parecer se está formando un triángulo
aquí abajo este triángulo de acá verdad
ahora podría ser tentador seguir
avanzando y seguir avanzando hasta este
punto de acá pero no no eso no vale
mucho la pena porque si llego hasta aquí
no voy a saber cuánto es la base de este
triángulo parece ser como que es como un
medio pero no podría estar seguro
es mejor voy a llegar nada más hasta
aquí y voy a completar el triángulo por
abajo entonces tendríamos algo así y
sale pero como ya empecé a dibujar de
abajo hacia arriba ahora voy a continuar
hacia arriba para encontrar otra figura
y a la derecha parece ser que se está
haciendo otro triángulo verdad una vez
más me voy a quedar hasta aquí porque
este cachito quién sabe cuánto mida
entonces ahora me fijo que aquí hay otro
triángulo que voy a completar de este
lado como por acá un poquito más arriba
como por acá y en realidad estos dos
triángulos ya es muy fácil calcular su
área verdad este de aquí tiene un lado
que mide 5 y un lado que mide 1 este de
acá tiene un lado que mide 4 y un lado
que mide 2 así que ahorita que
calculemos sus áreas va a ser muy
sencillo pero déjame seguir dividiendo
el cuadrilátero en figuras más pequeñas
entonces ya empecé a hacer esta línea la
voy a seguir para allá voy a seguir
seguir seguir seguir seguir seguir hasta
llegar a este punto
saleh llegó a este punto porque aquí
arriba tengo otro vértice que me ayuda y
ahora puedo bajar
puesto más a la izquierda puedo bajar
bajar bajar llegar ahí y continuar
continuó hasta topar con este punto de
acá y eso está fantástico ya logré
dividir ya logré dividir este este
cuadrilátero en cuatro triángulos que
tienen lados enteros
tienen lados enteros y este rectángulo
que queda aquí en medio y para esos ya
es bien fácil calcular su área este
triángulo de acá tiene un lado 5 y otro
1 el rectángulo aquí entonces su área
sería 5 por 1 entre 2 el área sería un
medio por 5 5 por 1 y eso es 5 medios o
sea 2.5 el área de este triángulo es 2.5
en el de acá tenemos altura 4 y tenemos
base 2 entonces su área es un medio de 2
por 4 o sea 42 por 48 a la mitad es 4
vamos a éste de acá tiene altura 2 y
tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 de base entonces su
área sería 6 por 2 12
entre 26 muy bien y estoy acá tiene base
1 y altura 5 entonces es como el de aquí
abajo verdad su área también es 2.5 es
la mitad de 5 y bueno yo con eso ya
tenemos el área de los triángulos ya
nada más nos falta la de este cuadrado
de acá y este cuadrado déjame tomar otro
color es un cuadrado de altura 3 y de
base 4 entonces su área es 3 x 4 o sea
12 con esto ya tenemos este cuadrilátero
dividido en regiones que conocemos su
área de modo que el área total sería
sumar todo esto 2.5 con 2.55 más 4 es 34
es 9 massey 6 15 más 12 es 27 entonces
el área sería 27 unidades cuadradas